Hello.
(Let me just just start.
Just 1/2.
So you introduce me first, right?
Yep. Just wanted to make sure that
it started, and it looks like we have so.)
Hello and welcome everyone to Active Lab.
This is Active Lab Gueststream number 6.1.
And we're really happy to be here
with Dr.
Anna Ciaunica.
So, Anna, thanks so much for joining.
We really appreciate it.
And we're looking forward to this talk.
Please just take it away.
And if anyone in the live chat
wants to ask a question,
I will relay those questions to you
at the end of this talk.
So thanks again for coming on the stream
and we're looking forward
to what you have to share.
Thank you so much, Danielle,
and thank you so much for having me.
Today.
I'm going to present a paper
that we worked on the past,
past year and just came out.
But I'm going to start very briefly
with some of my background
as a researcher.
So I'm trained
as an armchair philosopher.
So I did in
philosophy.
So I did my thesis on physical exam
in Qualia,
you know, the famous Mind-Body Problem.
So, exactly.
So some physical stuff
connects with, you know, mental stuff
and gets, you know, done.
It gives my students to experience
in our conscious experiences
like the heart problem of consciousness.
And I was obsessed
when I was any respectable philosopher,
philosopher with,
you know,
the high problem of consciousness
and whether there is something special
about the subjectivity
of our conscious experiences.
Right.
Because I'm coming from Burgundy. Yeah.
I spent a lot of time trying to,
you know,
say that there is something about our
there is something special
about our subjective conscious experience
because there is something
what is, is like from a sort of taste,
a particular wine
and coming from Burgundy,
I had a lot of experience in that,
an example with that.
But more recently I decided to get off
to armchair philosophy
and I recently started to collaborate
with people from cognitive science.
I actually also have a master of science
in developmental psychology,
and I'm recently
collaborating with cognitive neuroscience
at UCL in London.
And my job there is to ask the question
to scientists like,
What do you mean by perception?
What do you mean by social light?
So give us some examples.
So one of the annoying questions
I really like to ask is,
um, you know,
whenever I go to a conference it is,
I ask people to look around them
in the audience and realize that
actually there are new infants
in the audience,
just adults.
And I interpolate them on that.
And they look at me say,
you know, I don't see the point.
Why is this important?
Well, it is important because I mean,
when we start to investigate in mind
bodies, we already have an adult
centric theoretical lens.
So this means that the way we look at the
phenomena is from a certain standpoint
and extend that to using innovative
inescapably is in adult one, right?
So this means that we may have a sort of
like implicit bias towards certain
phenomena, a certain way of understanding
phenomena that is somehow,
you know, adult centric.
And we need to be careful
if we want to understand how mind and
how mind
and brain work in the first place.
So given that my initial,
you know, entrance point into science
and philosophy
was like perceptual awareness,
like the fundamental point of contact
was subject with the reality
of the objects of the world.
So this is like the fundamental way
of actually structuring an experience.
So we have this access,
we have an experience of subject
with a latent subject over there.
And typically this is this is how self
consciousness is understood, like
perceptual awareness
when one perceives oneself
as self distinct
from the world in others. And
how is that linked to self-recognition
in the mirror of my sister?
So for instance, like is the famous
Rorschach test, if you recognize yourself
numerous as a toddler and you see that
the person in the mirror is a student,
you know, take your positive reviews
from your forehead.
And that's supposed to give you a sign
that you are basically self
conscious and self aware.
But what I want to say
is that maybe by endorsing that
and our central perspective,
we tacitly also endorse the sort of
like visual spatial perspective on what
perceptual awareness needs from them.
From the very beginning.
So while I was doing
my first post-doc on In Philosophy
on the sensory model basis of the self,
I also started to do amazing
cognitive science
and developmental psychology,
and I started to actually address
the question of receptor awareness
in a slightly different angle.
And instead of asking myself
what you know, what is perceptual
awareness sees or what self-conscious
senses of self-awareness is?
I decided to ask the question How we do?
We really get in contact with the world
at most primitive level?
How do our self-awareness experience
or perceptive awareness
or experiences more general emerge
from the food chain in the first place?
So they unfold the lifespan,
and if you take that perspective right,
then you realize that actually
from the very beginning
we have that that traditional access
subject here related with an object
that is somehow incorrect
because in real life,
the way we start actually perceiving
the world is with the subject here
that relates with another subject here
in a very proximal way.
Right.
So this means that we'll probably need
to shift the perspective in
sort of like taking like the tacit visual
spatial understanding
of what the perceptual awareness sees.
We need to actually expand
it and be more exclusive. And
you know, pay attention to the fact
that our first experience
are basically multisensory nature
and also proximal dispute and distance.
Like we basically before
we meet other people's minds,
we meet other people's body.
And why is this important
is because there is a huge literature
on, you know, what does it mean for what?
What is a minimal self.
And actually, this is important
for not only for philosophy.
So for
science and robotics and many,
many other fields,
because it is important to
quickly define what
but really what we really mean
by a self and by minimal self and
is a huge literature
in a form that from various tradition
that, you know,
talk about minimal self-consciousness,
minimal self core self
print, reflective sense of self, etc..
And I think if we switch the perspective
and take
and almost like a more inclusive
ecological and bottom up approach
and what the meaning of self is, we avoid
a fallacy, sento conceptual fallacy.
So for instance, I'm trying to depict
this fallacy with this picture here.
So suppose you want to find out what is
a minimal model of a self-organizing
system such as a plant or a human?
And then if you take if you notice
an adult centric perspective,
then you might tempted to basically
take whatever structure we have
as an adult plant or an adult human.
And squeeze those property.
We'll try to, you know, extremely extract
the excision or disrupt
the basic structure of those property.
And then to say, okay,
so this is how the minimalist self model
of that self-organizing system,
it's right like a squeeze the plant
and make it small.
I say this is what the minimal model is.
But the reality we know very well
that actually this is not how it looks.
Right.
So for instance, if you can see here
that plant that the minimal level
you know, the form, the stroke structure
here is very different
than the ones that you have later on
in, say, the adult life.
So this means that we need to,
if we want to extract,
you know, the basic skeleton of a certain
system, then we need to be
from an ecological
and dynamic perspective.
We need to take into account
all the intermediary forms
in order
to make sure that actually understand
what the plant is
and what the human instrument.
So this is a paper
that we, as I say,
that we recently published this year.
So we decided to really,
really go back to the beginning
and to question
more carefully just ideas like
embodiment and cognitive stages.
And I want to start with a disclaimer
because this is very much work
in progress
and there is a lot of work to do
because this is, as I said, it's
a slow it's a shift in perspective.
So there is a lot of work
to do actually to shake a bit.
You know,
the entrance points to the problem
and this is not an active inference
account
of embodiment and analysis, yet
this is a work in progress.
I'm doing this on different levels from,
you know, metabolism to,
you know, more high level level
like self-awareness.
But because I need to start somewhere,
we decided with my collaborators
basically
to use active inference approach
some of the insights
of the active inference approach
to bring the fundamental set of core
embodiment of homeostasis
under the spotlight.
Because this is something
that we need to do
because it's like it's not mainstream.
So we decided to okay,
so let's take the sort of like meta level
approach, use active
in, for instance, and show that if you,
if you like the active in principle,
which is to endorse it, then you
you need to take into consideration
this kind of like very low level
core embodiment of approach
from the, from the very beginning.
So this is what we're going to do
in this paper.
So I'm going to start very briefly
with the background
and predict a processing framework.
I'm sure that you are all familiar
with this,
so I'm not going to spend a lot of time
explaining it,
but I just have two slides
we need to use
because I need to make sure
that if someone is looking watching this
and doesn't know what active influencer
pricing is, we are on the same page.
And then I'm going to spend actually
more time and trying to develop the
just and
motivate this need to actually take
a bottom up developmental
take on what perceptual awareness
and experiences in the first place
and define the notion of embodiment.
You see the services and communal spaces,
homeostasis,
but again,
I'm going to define them through this
bottom up developmental lens
and I'm going to end
with some hand-waving work in progress.
And I'm very open to suggestions
because as I said, this is like very much
an open question and we need
there is a lot more work to do.
Okay.
So I'm, I, I believe
if you are all familiar
with the predictive processing framework.
So the basic idea is that our brains
is not a passive sponge
that automatically somehow
passively receives information
and somehow, you know,
keeps the motor output.
But rather we should conceive the brain
as a sort of like active system
that anticipates the next sensory
input on the basis of prior inputs,
such as it actually can map the world
in a more accurate way.
This idea
very nicely fits with some previous idea
that having been developed in parallel
by embodied cognition,
a paradigm approach in cognitive science,
but they basically just order
like very long colleagues,
basically outlining this idea
that cognition should be understood
as nothing but
the world
and the mind on the basis of history
prior to a function
that the world performs in, in the sense
like we cannot really understand
cognition in isolation from the body
and we cannot understand
a body in isolation from the environment,
and we cannot understand either
the body or to know the relation
between the mind body and the environment
without take into account
the history of those like the connection
from the in the first place.
Right, because it's not static phenomena,
but it's more like dynamic
and follows over time
because this is what life is, right?
So this means that our ongoing
perception, cognitive processes
in action are influences
by prior events and prior experiences.
So this is something that, you know,
body cognition approaches and
predictive approaches somehow agree
on a different level of explanation.
But the basic idea is that so
you cannot consider this phenomenon
in isolation, isolation
from past events, right?
So designing
so another I think common ground
is this idea
that humans are biological agents
that emerge as like proactive survival
enable prediction machines,
which are strived to reduce uncertainty
within a highly volatile environment.
So basically trying to make sense
environment out there because, you know,
the world is bigger than our heads
and we try to find a way
to actually navigate this bigger world,
which is highly unpredictable and
partitioning, potentially threatening.
So one idea is that in order
to keep track of the survival
and reproduction, relevant body and world
information, our brain solves
that problem of uncertainty
by generating self and world models.
And it does so by certain statistical
patterns of information
from its own body and world interaction.
And there is a mathematical
story behind it is I'm
not a mathematician, I'm a philosopher.
You know,
leave that to the mathematician.
But I think what I need as a philosopher,
I need just this idea that
you know, our ongoing perception,
cognition and action and process
through the lens of prior self and work
related information.
So this is what I need information.
I need to only see it.
Now, if this is true,
then this means that
it becomes crucial to look at
how this experience in action perception
gets off the ground from the outset.
Right, because we need that balance
to be accurate, right?
In a dynamic and ecological way.
One basic, basic and overlooked aspect
of our embodied and predictive process
seeing approaches in both philosophy
and cognitive neuroscience,
is that brains in mind and human bodies
first develop within another human body.
And this is important point,
because crucially, while not
all humans will have the experience
of being pregnant or carrying a baby,
the experience of being caring, growing
within another person is universal.
So this is something that all humans
are concerned with, right?
So and this is something
important as well
because way before we meet
other people's minds, we literally need
to logically meet other people's bodies.
And it's something I developed
already, too.
So in 2017, when I looked at empathy
in basic for shared experience.
But the idea is to say it's like,
okay, so if we really want to understand
the relation between
mind, body and how,
you know, embodied creature
relate with other with others and well,
we really need to go back to this basic
idea that yeah,
before we meet other people's minds,
we literally meet other people's body.
So there is a
lot of work, previous work
that show that looked at
the homeostatic and body mechanism
operating
at early stage of developing in infancy.
So post about right
we decided to take a step further
and to focus on pregnancy
because this is a universal case.
Remember I I'd like to emphasize this
because typically, you know,
when people hear the word pregnancy,
so okay, this is a woman's stuff
because I mean, certain certain people,
certain person
give you a pregnancy, the other don't.
So but if you take the perspective,
the other perspective, then you realize
that actually all segments are concerned
with this experience, right?
Where to invigorate, to organize,
literally grasp and grip into each other
and contrary to the common view that
if a fetus is passively contained
and so is, you know,
sometimes is put is like solipsistic,
is trapped within the solitude,
in the silence of the womb,
we would present
evidence showing that
actually there is a lot of good nondairy.
Indeed there is an active
in bidirectional correlation
between the two living bodies
and living organism
and we need to start
with some basic definitions.
So first of all, I'm
going to talk a lot about embodiment,
but we need to make clear what exactly
we mean by embodiment in the first place.
There is a lot of work already
in the literature underlying the relation
between the body and self,
and I recommend this like
very recent review by Kim and colleagues
comes from your note of love
to have a rich overview of
the relation between the body, self
and self-awareness.
But here I'm going to use my analytical
philosophy card
and I'm going to define body
mind in its minimal form
to refer to the instantiation of bodily
properties by a given individual,
in our case, the human.
Now the well, it's
all talk about embodiment Kandace
conceptually ontologically linked
to talk about embodied beings
and and and they bodily properties.
Now the key starting idea here is
that brain in mind is
said is like fatigue and body cognition
approaching us for more recently
like public policy
and active inference approach.
It's like they all seem to agree that
the human brain and minds don't emerge
in a vacuum, but develop and evolve
as a system dedicated to controlling.
And so the organic survival
and reproduction.
So basically
if you take the classical mind body
instead of collect perceiving the body
as sort of like a vehicle or car that's,
you know, it's there to support
and fuel the mind.
Actually,
you should consider the other way
around, namely that the mind has evolved
to actually serve
the needs of a organism, right of a body
of your human body.
So you basically shift the perspective
which not which is actually
which comes first,
which one is actually more important. So
crucially, however,
if so, if we endorses perspective
and we agree with this shift,
then we need to consider the fact
that human bodies
do not imagine of outcome either.
Right?
So human body is basically emerge
and develop within another human body.
So this means that we need to adopt
an extended notion of simple
what it means to reflect
this fundamental body within a body case,
which, again, I'm going to stress again
and again, this is a universal right.
It's not just like a part
of the population.
So but what does it mean to say
that the two agents are embodied?
Well,
in biological terms?
This means that to see later,
very shortly is that the regular
nation of the two agents states
and particularly
they need to maintain that
physiological stability,
despite the fact that an
and unpredictable environment is actively
negotiated between the two organisms
that share for a given amount of time,
typically nine months, but the shorter,
a bit longer common and bodily
and environmental resources.
Right.
And I need to give you an example.
So what exactly I mean by embodiment,
because I think this is a key point.
So I'm going to ask you to walk with me
into a thought experiment
because I'm a philosopher,
so I'm going to present you
with this little experiment.
So you imagine you
you have a friend and you, you know,
you, you, you have to perform a sequence
show, right?
And with your friend and you have to
share this pair of trousers here.
So your friend puts you
his left leg in the left
part of the shirt of his trousers,
and you put the right leg
on the right part of the problem services
and you need to coordinate your walking
such as actually you can walk as fast
as you can to actually reach a target
right on opposite
no. Suppose that your friend's
as hitting his toe against rock stumbles
and falls and experience there by fear.
So with this happening in his body,
in his organism.
Right?
So this means that maybe your friend
is going to and train you in
or in which case
you can say that the two bodies,
I mean, you are the friend causally,
but you share the state of like
falling to get.
And you can also see that well
because this kind of like negative event,
your frames, your friend is kind of like
experiencing fear and you also
experiencing fear as well while falling.
Right?
So you share that state of
fear.
Not crucially, however, that
this is not necessarily so.
So suppose, for instance, that you know,
your friend is
is a master yoga teacher.
Right.
And while you are fully your
your friend is somehow manage
to keep the balance
and you know what the you know,
the tissue of the trousers thing of like,
you know, destroyed and, you know, one
standing at other one is falling, right?
It's not necessarily.
So you can imagine a case
that actually this is happening.
And also imagine a case in which,
let's say, well,
why your friend is falling
and experiencing fear.
You find entire situation or treatment
20% of experiencing
fear, your experience, amusement trait.
So the two emotional states are not
shared, necessarily shared.
So your friend experiencing fear, your
experience, let's say amusement, right?
So that's one example of like what
we can understand by sharing a state.
Now let us go back to the case
of pregnancy.
Right?
Not that the case of pregnancy
is very different,
because if you take exactly
the same example and say
that the mother is like some stems
into an opinion or something and,
you know, false, then there is no way
in which the fetus can say,
wait a minute, actually, I'm not
I don't like the situation.
I don't want to fall.
I don't want to fix fear
and I don't want to experience negative,
you know, emotion.
I'm going to sit stay put here you go.
It's all right.
So this means that actually
there is a way in which the two states
are the two organisms are necessarily
linked, such as the body itself.
Regulatory processes of one
organ is necessarily
is linked to the other one.
So it is important to distinguish
the case of pregnancy from the case
of two bodies like contingently happen
to share a state.
Right.
And we can this doesn't find a notion
of like embodiment and saying that two
or more if you have twins or
more than 3 to 2
of kids are quite voided
and a strong case if they are bound to
share bodily and environmental resources
for a set time period, typically
nine months for survival purposes.
Not that pregnancy is not the only case
where we can find instances of disciples
like stalk strong embodiments.
Like for instance, this is siblings,
but we decided to focus
on the case of pregnancy
because as I said,
this is universal case.
All humans have,
you know, experienced this.
So there is already work
on the fascinating
phenomenology of shared embodiment,
and I highly recommend to to read it
in what follows.
Basically, I'm going to very quickly
go to start with a very basic
level, actually what is happening.
God, you know, from single cell
going up that organism
and that kind of like shared, shared
embodiment.
Again, this is the fascinating, a huge
literature when you think about it.
We said was like this
tiny little round thing
with another person body
and then we become ourselves.
So again, I'm going to be very quick
and very sketchy on this like fascinating
process, but then I'll try to flag,
you know, the two crucial steps
and a crucial stages, right?
So the first stage
is the process of implantation.
So basically when there is a dialog
between the fertilized
egg and demand the body.
Right.
And this is actually
this is the crucial step of a pregnancy,
the successful pregnancy,
because, for instance,
most of the miscarriages
happen during this step.
This is a
like a sort of like negotiation process
going on between the two organisms saying
and like any negotiation
that things can go okay or can go wrong.
Right.
So this means that both the plasticity
in the baby and the endometrial tissues,
they need to actively regulate
gene expression, transcription factor
signaling pathways,
inhibiting factors and growth factors
doing that implantation process.
This is highly complex process
and very fragile and very delicate.
If something goes
wrong, can go to miscarriage or
did they do wrong and pull the lead
this stage the maternal
by the literally cells modify
some of through differentiation
into specific type
that support implantation right
so the key idea here is the embryo
and the mother's body need to coordinate
with these cells within that
very tiny implantation window.
Right now,
if this process, let's suppose,
is like successful,
then the coordination goes
to the next step
between week seven and 13, most movements
that involve self-organization can start.
So and and a self-organization,
interestingly, involves movement,
which is actually very important
because especially
for the active inference community,
because as you say, as you can see,
actually movement
is present very early on in our lives.
So these movements are initiated
from the so called
pattern generator
in the early spinal cord,
which produces around eight very abrupt
startles or the entire fetal body.
Quite
importantly, not that this photos
which are somehow automatic, right?
We think of like a sort of
like heartbeat.
I just think, you know, automatically
provide the minimal basis
for the most basic occasion,
sensory feedback
because in doing so, for instance
and my started to phase
in that sort of thing how my hand,
you know, would magically
or unwilling to touch my face.
And then I received a slight sensory
feedback on my face from my right hand
where my leg might change its position,
be flex or extended or both.
So this means that
I may have some meaningless sensory
feedback at this stage that that full
the possibility
to respond and adapt to this movement.
This means that self-organization
in fetal movement initiate
as a biomechanical process
that progressively builds sensory
and regulatory capacities.
So for example, as
is said, by being stimulated by startle,
the fetus perceives
that the hand is movable
and that touching the face
rather than the uterine wall with
and might feel different
because I'm more sensitive here
in the face that actually I can't
I can feel my I can feel my fingertips
if I touch to you doing more.
But if I touch my own face here,
have a double touch.
Right.
Okay.
So with this in hand, we can go further
to this notion of homeostasis.
And bear in mind
that this is all happening.
So we have a developing body
within another body
now homeostasis typically refers to
the organism
need to maintain and stable
organic internal environment
despite fluctuating external environments
right
and human university regulation
typically entails using feedback
control mechanism to keep the senses
viable of that internal environment
within the rages competition
for survival.
In this case, for compatible
human survival.
Now it is one established
that this control involves
automatic actions like motor reflexes,
endocrine logical autonomic processes
that are
driven by the feedback inputs
and the resulting prediction error,
which is the discrepancy
between the expected body state
at the extent set point
and its actual level
as signal by the sensory
inputs from the body.
And as early as 1929
it has been proposed.
That may be the control body
homeostasis closest to the primary
aim of the brain function right.
And this is, again, this underlying
assumption is that the fundamental drive
towards like self-preservation
to take this body to self
is essentially just restraint of acting
within the body's visual states.
Right.
So it has been classically proposed
to define the homeostatic symptoms
and expectation,
the means of prior beliefs
about the states
the body should inhibit, inhabit
and homeostatic range
as the variance of this operate. But
now going back to our case, right,
so let's go back to the two,
you know, just for one
or the primitive level, so many years,
it has been assumed that a fetus
has no metabolism of its own.
Right
now is nowadays is well established
that actually the placenta
in the fetal liver working and then
as a sort of coordinating
multi organ system to provide
in the so nutrients
serving the fetal growth.
And this is important because you know
if you talk about homeostasis,
we need to talk about metabolism, right.
Because that, of course,
is the most important fuel for
fetal metabolism
and ultimately for human states.
So this means that maintaining
an optimal balance
as a continuous supplies of nutrients
from the mother to the fetus is critical
from the development
and from the fetal status
standpoint is basically critical
for maintaining his own
homeostatic balance.
Now note that the fetus may be able
to control and save some energy
to some extent through many complex
and dynamic processes.
But importantly, however it is
oversupplied on undersupply of nutrients
by the mother, right, which are process
controlled by the pregnant person
that can permanently program
the fetal metabolism adversely.
Right.
So this means that
the way the mother
handles her own
metabolic processes significantly
impacts the way, you know, the baby's is,
you know, has his self-regulatory
process maintained
and there is accumulating evidence
that there is a direct link
between mothers adverse bodily
and mental health states like depression
and anxiety during pregnancy and child
medium mental and physical development.
But this is this is not only for
this is valid, not only for the negative
states, but also more like neutral states
such as food preferences
and flavors that are passed on
from the mother to the infant.
So there is a strong, strong
codependent step
now that the key entered
into the intermediate conclusion
at this stage is that emerging
self-organizing organism,
human organism,
is not only self centric,
but also crucially embodied.
It could, depending upon homeostatic
processes within do the environment.
Right.
So does the basic thesis up to know.
Now we need to take this a step further
because
we need to talk about
also action, anticipation
and not just like our prediction
or perception.
So we saw up to now
that homeostatic regulation requires
some order that many people's
inference, perception
and prediction absence selection.
Importantly, however, the brain
initiate regulatory responses
prior to luminosity cultivation providing
that can be anticipated.
So this means that you basically act
to go
to the fridge to seek food
because you are hungry,
but actually are not.
You're not to wait.
You're not waiting for the starvation
to happen to actually go to the fridge.
You do it away before.
That actually is going to happen.
So you anticipate that distinct.
So this means
that high level that enable perspective
control are leveraged with
two essential components like inference
and prediction, which I think is
and thesis which is defined
as anticipatory, almost control.
Basically you take action to the world
because you need to regulate your,
you know, almost static balance.
But you are doing this by taking action
into into the world.
And importantly, you're doing this
by anticipating that state.
You don't really expect
to be on the age of like,
you know, dying from starvation
to actually take that action
if you are optimal,
you know, surviving organism.
So this means that the process
whereby the agent selects action
that will most probably bring
about the desire since entries,
while explicitly
or implicitly more defined a true cause,
the structure of the environment
such as the guarantee direct rains
of those inputs over multiple times.
So this means that I can act differently
in different environments.
I can go to the fridge if I'm hungry,
but if I'm the desert,
I could, you know, if
if I expect to see a fridge and,
you know, I don't see it, then I'm
going to probably die.
Instead of looking for food
I should probably look for,
I don't know, banana tree or coconut
tree. Right.
So the environment defines
what type of expectation
you should have in a particular case.
Now, there are two points
that are important here.
Not that
in the individual organism, homeostatic,
I mean, we can perceptually distinguish
from acidic processes,
from anesthetic processes,
but in real life those go hand in
hand, in hand.
Right
to that are two phases of the same coin.
This is because we humans,
we are not static, isolated creatures,
we are dynamic bees depending on the rich
environment, environmental resources,
and we depend upon social interaction
to achieve survival in production.
And you can read like the basic example
that I really like is the like
breathing. Like
it's a perception.
So it's an open ended process, right?
We are constantly exchanging information
with environment via
EEG. Right?
And this is a dynamic process
because my body moves
right to
my automatic cage is moving all the time.
And this means that those type
of processes like
to study processes in homeostatic
processes, even though we can
conceptually distinguish in reality
they actually occur.
This means that perception and action,
homeostatic and anesthetic regulation are
copied, strongly copied in a dynamic loop
that keeps the organism permeable
to and connected with this surroundings
for better and for worse.
Because when I breathing,
I can take the air, right?
That is necessary oxygen for my survival.
But I can also continue
taking the coronavirus, you know,
and you know, eventually
you potentially die, right?
So we are open system for better
and for worse in that sense, right?
The second point is that going
back to our case here is in pregnancy,
is that self-regulatory
architecture is multilayered.
This is an interesting point here. Right?
It's like it's already
complicated for individual.
But imagine we're actually
two individuals
that are actually grouped
into each other. Right.
Because the babies regulatory processes
are complete with the mother's
homeostatic analysis
processes.
And this is achieved
mainly through the placenta,
which is an ephemeral
and intermediary organ, and that enables
vital and biological exchanges
between the two bodies.
And, for example, it allows the infant
to breathe despite a lack of proper,
proper lung regulation
and ensure that the infant is
fed despite lacking
proper eating effectors.
Not again,
that placenta is the relational
excellence,
but is also a universal organ.
Typically, people associate placenta
with like the female body
and a certain type of population
to do the certain type of persons.
But we all have cues
all humans have used successfully
this organ in order to survive.
And you know, I don't know do philosophy,
cognitive science and active influence
later on in their lives.
Right.
And this is important
to keep in mind now. And
I'm right, this means that the dynamic
and complex systems
such as the human body
needs to be able to play a double game
in order to survive
and potentially reproduce.
It has to successfully maintain
sensory stays within a certain
physiological bounds,
but it also has to flexibly change
the state in order to adapt
to constantly changing environment.
So if we look at the human body
through through this dynamic lens
and become obvious that what happens in
between the organism, its environment,
I mean the boundaries between it to play
a key role in making sure this game
is correctly played and flexible
to actually maintained organs for life.
So this means that we need to find
a Christian
critical notional boundary
or in-between, right?
We need a new perceptual toolbox
in order to make sure
that we get that process correctly.
Right.
And this is something I'm currently
working on with some collaborators
and some some of you probably know that,
you know,
the notion of a macro blanket,
a macro blanket being
advocate as a potential candidate
to a promising way of conceptualizing
this key notion of the boundary,
the medium between the two.
And again, this is like
a work in progress and there is like
a lot of work to be done that's say.
But for all this talk, I,
I really need to
retain is like very simple idea
that homeostatic
and anticipatory self regulation depends
not only on the body states,
but also on the external environment
and more crucially on the relation
between the two.
So we can define cool homeostasis
by direction process of coagulation
that happens in between to combat it.
Organism and homeostasis involves
self regulation.
It's through others couplet
and homeostatic and prosthetic loopy
states not knowing
that.
And this is something that we had.
You know what could be with
a few of us on our paper.
And they were kind of like, right.
Bracing clarification on this point,
because it's important to bear in mind
that if we talk about
by direction, process doesn't mean
there is a symmetry
or absence of conflict
when the country actually
things can go wrong, right.
In the sense like
it can be that, you know, one
one agent actually takes the balance
too much in one sense, then other.
And to give you an example,
like what exactly what I mean by that.
So think of the highway, right?
So you can have it that's that's a
by direction
highway traveling from north to south.
Let's say
that you have typically more cars
coming from not to the south and mean
from the mother to the infants.
But you have these can have one single
car traveling from south to north
and that car is like
you know, I don't know, carrying bomb
and actually that's the relevant right
it's not the quantity
that matters is actually
the quality of the information
that is carried
between the two organisms.
You actually have many, many cases
and basically during the pregnancy,
I know a mother's a pregnant person
develop
diabetes or other immuno,
you know, logical disorders, right.
So it is not necessarily
a straightforward process,
as I said, and emphasizing this
this is a crucial negotiation
between the two organism.
It's a dynamic, open ended process
that can go okay,
but can also create a wrong.
Now, the big claim to radical claim
you want to make
is that given the necessary universal
keyboard in sustaining the human body
so regulation and self-organizing
processes from the outset
that early on this regulation
should be fundamentally conceived as core
regulation
and school Newman's thesis. Now
in a further
work we want to develop this idea
of when exactly
and how the brain
starts to be in the southern world
model in the womb.
Right.
Because it's like it's a key
question from for the,
you know, predictive processing
framework and active inference community.
So how exactly this is happening,
when exactly this is happening,
this is highly speculative
and is very much a work in progress.
So it's an open question whether
the fetus is able to generate a self
and while models
and if yes, at what stage of development.
Some people argue that this is
maybe be possible only after the basic
telomere cortical connection
are established in the fetal brain.
Around 10 to 20 weeks of gestation.
This is because
the main reason is because
after this time point, sensory
information can be transferred
to the fetal brain
before they establish of this term
of cortical connection to fetus just acts
honorifics automatic mode.
However, the people
argue that through the central
thought in generating the seemingly code
like spirit of movement, they also
can generate a sort of like sensory
motor coupling
and also very basic
primitive sensory experiences.
Again, this is like an open question
and this is something that I address
in a preprint.
Currently under review,
a two of my collaborator,
Adam Safran and Jonathan Delafield. But
we look at how exactly
self-awareness. No.
So how exactly the fact
that our first experiences are coy,
loaded impact
may impact the way we understand
current theories
of conscious experiences in general
and what
our provocative take is
that, you know, no consciousness study
focused too much on visual experiences
and a visual spatial way perspective.
And we're seeing a tacit, adult
centric and visual spatial perspective.
And we might say that perhaps conscious
experience are not all about seeing red
happens to, you know, a famous example.
So wider
implication of switching the perspective,
you know, from this
like what we understand
by minimum self and minimal of self
models, you know, from endorsing
more ecological bottom up perspective
other than adult centric
vision based perspective.
Again, this is very much a work in
progress, something that we are working
on right now.
But, you know,
just like bullet bullet points,
if we switch to perspective,
then we need to question
the individualistic and solipsistic
approach of understanding
the perceptual language
in the ancient environment.
We also need to question that US centric
species are sort of like fully fledged
emerging individuals
like, you know, Athena, the Greek
goddess
Athena coming us from the zoo head.
So rather than humans emerge
within other humans
and develop through close interaction
with other humans,
we also need to question
the idea of a self-awareness
for me myself developing
independently of other self citizens,
because as I hopefully,
you know, confused you, that we basically
are ontologically independent
from the others from the very beginning
at a very basic biological level
and then the question we need
to also question the idea of a perception
being a solitary, distant neighbor
like single redouble,
but rather we need to, you know,
see a perception as an active interaction
of active engagement with environment
like voice touching human being
or coupling down to receptive
like signaling like the breathing.
So the way I feel that inside my body
to where I take the air from outside
and also important
that perception of that perception,
that perception comes
before the seeing the red apple.
And if
this approach is right,
this means that that early primitive
perception influences
the way we perceive and see the red apple
later on in life.
And to take home message
is that when it comes to understanding
nature of our perception,
experience in general, but
also have an outlet for this
in this paper.
But then we are trying to build a case
for this idea
as well and conscious experience as well.
The infant is father to the man,
to the human.
Sorry, it's paraphrased this
metaphor by the English poet Wordsworth.
And this is it.
I would like to thank my collaborators
for working with me
on this like radical project.
I would like to thank the organizing of
the Arctic influence now for inviting me.
And I also I would like to ask you
that if you are interested
to collaborate with me along those lines
of like paradigm shift, please
drop me any more because I'd say open
to decide, use and to develop further.
And this is it and thank
you for your attention.
Excellent. That was really interesting.
Maybe you can share
and we'll have a little bit of time
to discuss. Cool.
So if anybody wants to post a question,
they're free to do so.
I have a bunch of thoughts in question,
but one piece that right at the beginning
you mentioned it
the historical nature of inaction.
And it just shows that sometimes
when people
are talking about inactive approaches,
they're, oh, you know, picking up
this pen, it's the snapshot in activist.
But actually the implications of action
are that we have to think about history
and development.
So I really appreciate the way
that you framed it in in these terms.
So maybe just to get things
started, where does active inference
come into play here?
That's a pretty big question.
But where does active reference
come into play?
Yeah.
So I think that active inference
come into play in the way
we actually understand how
the minimal sound is construed, right?
So how the minimal self-organizing system
is somehow negotiated, that exchange
of information between, you know,
his own self model and the environment.
Right?
So the radical idea
we want to put forward
is that the closest environment
and the most primitive environment
that we have in the first place
is another human body, is not some sort
of like objective environment,
but in other subjective,
I mean, lived or lived,
you know, body, right?
So I think that's kind
of like radical idea
and it means that we basically
we need to not add an extra level
even more dynamic to the active influence
to say it's just not enough
to basically just act
and to make sense of that actually
in the world, in the movement.
But actually we need to take it
as a sort of like double way.
It's a call coordination
between the two organisms, right?
So it's not just
like an ace,
it's like cool action and call movement.
So it just means that it's even more
messier than we thought at the beginning.
It's like if you take, you know, the
the standard approach, right?
So you have two environment to agent
and then the agent
needs to be
in the model of that environment.
So by contrast in whatever self
internal self more that says and what it
and extracting
the mapping of the environment has right
now, you need to take into account
that that the kind of like environment
is not only just like
in another agent out there
that you need to interact with
and that the agent can be, I don't know,
another human being or a robot.
Right.
But actually you share common
resources, computational resources way
that another agent's right
and you need to actively negotiate
those resources on the fly
might even though
there is kind of like a asymmetry
because obviously the pregnant
person has way more power.
You know, she can
he can move around and
act in the world.
But that coordination
happens from from the very beginning.
That makes me wonder,
how is it related to niche construction?
That's something that actual constant
has, of course, worked a lot on.
So how do we think about niche
construction?
Is there a niche?
A shared niche is one,
the niche of the other.
Yeah.
So that's that's I mean this is like,
as I said, this is an emerging field
and I have something like a zillion
questions, an interesting question to us
and. One of those is like related
to the new
constructions process of
and it's like somebody says
so the the pregnant person, right.
So there is like
very nice work showing that
because also the
mother is embedded in a wider social
and physical environment.
So we have cultural constraints
on that pregnant person.
And there is work showing that,
you know, for instance, like,
you know, the, the,
the maternal, for instance, influences
the way the infant will later on cry
and feel and also even the niche.
So to speak, for this is baby language.
Well, because I don't know, the father
speaks one language
and the mother speaks another language
and also impacts the way, for instance,
the the infant later on cry or,
you know, coordinates.
Right.
So this but again,
this is emerging evidence.
We need way more work
to actually carefully
look at that exchanges between, you know,
the body subject the body
subject to pregnant subject
and it's like close environment.
But what we know for
sure is that clearly I mean,
I mean,
the the the the social background,
the cultural background and the physical
background is really, really important.
Try to direct direct impact and accident
does that that show I can't remember
the on the top of my head
the name of the mothers but I yeah.
Show quite nicely that actually you know
I don't know
strange babies or German babies
they don't cry the same way
because the language spoken by them,
the mothers, has different
intonation, right?
So the auditory input that you can have
in the womb
actually significantly impacts strength.
So this means that if you change niche,
the cultural nature
show a change of mind,
but you also want to change the way
the baby later on will somehow express,
you know, this regulatory process
like crying, right?
I'm not happy.
But that
makes me think about how even as adults,
we're still bounded
by externally constructed membranes.
We rely on a broader society to bring us
glucose and to take our waste.
And so there's critical period,
just like you had with the seed.
Absolutely a critical period
where just like for any other complex
system, it's going to have bifurcation
and a lot of leverage points
in its development
when it's literally more fluid.
But later on, these things are different
in kind of detail, but not in type.
So extremely.
Yeah, and I think it's very it's
really important because we, we,
we tend to
we need to
I mean, I forgot to pull that slide,
but I think it's important to bear in
mind what we call the invisible
basis of the AIDS iceberg, right?
So certain
things really take for granted.
So if you go again to the department
that.
Right. So for the treatment of war.
So think of a tree, right?
So you walk on a stretcher.
So let's suppose you are a martian,
right?
And you land on the earth in a tea tree
and understand how the tree works.
What is a tree? Right.
So if you limit yourself to only to what
you see the surface of the earth, right?
Like the trunk leaves, you know,
then you might need some important bits
of information how exactly tree works.
Because a tree also has roots.
And basically the way this negotiate
the nutrients through
that basic roots, invisible lines
actually
you know significant impacts
how later on I know
the trunk or leaves are constructed right
so we really need
this is our motivation to take to endorse
like bottom up developmental
and ecological dynamical perspective
because we really need to go back
to the roots invisible
one that we take for granted because
as you said rightly point out,
maybe there is something going on
at that critical stage
that if you act upon that critical stage,
then you avoid later on bigger problems
that you can't modify.
So you need to
act exactly at the time t
for a very specific reason,
but also those roots are highly connected
with,
I don't know, the nutrients in the earth
in this case, like
mother's body, which the mother body
is kind of like connected again
with a closed environment.
I mean, the way he she is like supported
or the cultural background,
that type of support
you get from her close environment.
And I try and then,
you know, I don't know, going higher up
and it's like policies that, you
know, governments can have and you know,
climate change and other things, right.
So it's everything is somehow
a very open and precarious system.
And I think this is so
I mean, the way I understand and this is
why I'm interested in this like entire,
you know,
new active infant approaches, people
as well as name shows.
It's like it's an acting thing, right?
It's like it's
constantly, dynamically moving.
We need to make sense of it, right?
In very,
you know, rigorous way.
But still, you know,
it's an open ended process and.
Yep, and for the tree, visually,
the roots are there.
But with humans, our roots are often
transient or they're cultural.
So it also asks us to move beyond
a visual representation
of being tangled in a web.
And you can't move, but rather
to see these dynamical processes
that go through the developing embryo.
So here's a question from the chat.
@Ana [Clara de Paula] asks
saying that they just came
to see your talk
after hearing about it
just a few minutes before it began.
So that's so fun that we can connect
with people
who are just hearing about these ideas
maybe for the first time.
And the question is,
I would like to ask for
background references
to start studying this theme.
So what would be some key references
or some key questions
or topics to look up for somebody
who's kind of wanting to follow you
on that freeway
on research trajectory that you're on? So
so there are several.
So it depends on the backgrounds, right?
So there is
there is very nice
work on the phenomenology side.
So in philosophy, right?
So there's a nice work by Alina,
by and also by how do you go?
And I think
I hope I'm not misspelling her name,
but if you Google Annie Diego
she has a recently last year paper with
I'm sorry I've really bad names
so that's a very good reference
starting point
I also wrote on this
so if you Google my name
I started to work on this
already in 2017.
I worked on a basic form
of self-awareness, right.
And there is nice work on
that.
That did the touch and affective
touch component right now by
Maria.
Now roughly 30 times I want to Cuccinelli
dance very nice of you people up
and especially sugar to edited
it it's just cool so the special issue
called the relational
self basic forms of self
when they have a paper
that and actually have quite nice papers
there as well on this topic.
But more overall,
I wanted to say that I have
the Twitter handle public and there is
I also have my website and
in an office.
So I'm very happy to take emails
and you can basically forward
and I'm all,
you know complete reference
because on the top of my head,
I'm pretty sure I left aside
important references.
And I don't want to say I, you know,
I said this reference
that got those references
so much diplomatically.
So email me and I'm going to send you
a reference is what's interesting.
And it reminds me of the way
that now the Internet is allowing us
to be in very tight feedback loops,
more like a co embodiment of knowledge.
You're able to share your knowledge
and your perspective on things,
and then somebody can ask a question.
And now we're in a very tight
proximal communications wise cycle
where we can actually update each other
on, oh,
it was actually this 2017 citation
she was talking about, not the other one,
but if that was only once in a while
conversation, we couldn't
actually develop at this rate.
So that's quite interesting.
Again, as adults
who are co constructing each other's
ecological niche, okay, one thought I had
and if anyone can write
more questions, is in most insects.
So as an entomologist I was thinking
of insects most insects lay eggs
and you had said that the placenta
and the co embodiment,
the pregnancy is universal
and maybe it's mammalian.
In fact, it's. Defined as within humans.
Oh, yes, yeah.
Universal to. Humans. Yeah.
Yeah.
So the egg for the insects contains
everything
it needs to get to the relevant
life stage, like to hatch from the egg
and then b whatever stage of development
it's in,
except for the ants.
Well, there's other
exceptions here, but in the ants,
the larva is after the egg.
It hatches into a lava very quickly,
and then the larva is actually in a
two directional relationship.
And the larvae are called the social gut,
and they have a one handed gut.
And so they're being fed food
and actually digesting it.
And in a
two directional hormonal relationship.
And so it was so interesting that it's
almost like the length of the dialog,
the length of the intergenerational
transfer.
Is it one day, is it one year?
Is it 18 years?
Is it permanent?
Are we always co-creating the length
of that hand off
in the richness of the handoff
seems to have something to do
with the evolution of complexity.
So I was wondering
what you thought about that.
Yeah.
So this is amazing.
I mean, I mean, when you look at nature
is like mind blowing.
I mean, I was about to say it's like we
I mean, I'm talking
from the philosophy perspective,
I can safely say that the last year
has been kind of like the century and,
you know, you know, human centered,
anthropocentric, right.
But if you want to really,
it's like how mind and body works.
And you look at the nature more general
than you realize.
Well, this is really fascinating.
And so, you know, we can learn so much.
So you you
you are telling me about the islands.
But I recently read something because
I started to be fascinated by this idea
of like placenta and I've read that
surprising some lizards, right?
So you have
exactly
the same species of lizard, right.
And some them
and some of them actually have babies.
Right, exactly the same lizard.
And you ask yourself why?
And then you realize that actually
it depends the climate where they are
if they are a warm climate
or a cool climate, right?
So if they are in warm climate,
they lay eggs
because the sun is kind of like, no,
but if you are in the cold climate
only going keep the egg inside, right
and make the baby
keep their protective baby inside.
Right.
And then only after that baby kind of
they simply put it into the world.
Right?
So that's a very nice example of,
as you said, it's like the the
the flexibility and adaptability
that we can have to actually know
the man and climate happens
and carry on right?
Because in this case,
you basically have exactly the same body.
But the way you carry
your own life is depending on
exactly that in between interaction
that you have with the environment.
Right.
You know, cooling environment in one
case, in a warm environment in another.
And that impacts the way you basically
cool, you know, the way you
self-organize and reproduce.
It is really fascinating.
I really hope that basically,
you know, animal scientists
in general,
brain scientists would work hand in hand
because I'm pretty sure
will somehow unlock many of the so-called
mystery of the human mind,
that human body,
just by looking carefully
what is going on to our,
you know, friends and neighbors
and animals.
Right.
It's an excellent point.
And in animal cognition especially,
it's phrased as like the development
of the cognitive capacity,
as if that was the end point.
You know, you go from 0 to 60
and then you're at six,
then you cognitive decline,
you know, tap on the brakes.
But there's a richness
and it's different cognitive agents,
which actually
brought me to this question, which was
I was definitely with you, that the adult
centric perspective that you raised
in your first anecdote
at the conference and it's,
oh, it's all adults in the room
so let's go with this
that it would be fallacious
to have an adults only perspective
and maybe it might be also
somewhat of an error to have like a child
only philosophy, just whatever
the children appeals to them.
Let's just go with it.
So how do we structure
the intergenerational conversation
and learn from each other?
Yeah,
so that's that's a that's a big question.
So I think
what we really wanted to do in this paper
was like something very, very modest,
namely to draw attention on the fact,
hey, guys, pay attention.
We have this lens.
Yeah, it's kind of like to see it.
Let's
clean it a bit and expand it, right?
So I'm happy to basically expanded it
and take that
kind of like bottom up perspective.
But obviously I don't want to bring
everything to the to the root,
so to speak. Right.
Would be like exactly the same policy
to like focus
just like like on the foods,
like the apple, the tree
and focus just on the roots.
Right.
I think what we really need is
an explanation of that dynamic process.
Right. How that informs how that emerge.
I was connected
with the wider environment
and with other minds,
other bodies, other animals is
I don't
know if it's true, I need to check.
But at some point somebody told me,
I think I saw it on Twitter
that actually if you take a human body
and you take the cells and the human body
numerically actually have more
foreign cells than actually human cells
in your body numerically,
because all you have
most of my microbiota, I think. Right.
So if you if you take
just like that quantitatively,
then we basically are more in another
than actually in cells,
which is like
I need to check that information.
That's true.
That's actually quite interesting.
One one thought on that number of cells
is actually the CO embodiment
framework moves us beyond a numbers game.
For example,
there could be a very big system
in a small system
like the earth in the moon,
and yet the moon is relevant for this or,
that process on earth,
and that's because they don't
have to be symmetrical.
If it was a tug of war,
then it enforces a symmetry
which enforces a narrowness,
but actually it doesn't really.
What if it was really influential cells
or less influential cells
that can be accommodated
in an active inference
or in a dialog based framework,
but less so in a sort of.
There's only one way to collaborate,
like tit for tat or a game theory, which
is where a lot of the models of pregnancy
just are still scratching their head.
Right.
Here's
a little of a meta science question.
If anyone else has any
they can post to is it was really cool
how you demarcated
your thoughts on being a philosopher
and working with a formal theory.
So what are your thoughts
on working with formal isms
as a philosopher or working
on these transdisciplinary teams
where there might be colleagues
with clinical, psychological, math
and a philosophy background?
So how do we work together
on these teams and address
these topics that are really big?
Yeah, that's a that's a good question.
And sometimes it's like Twitter
is quite good for that
because I can just want me to get this
like the conflict in a nutshell.
So I remember
somebody tweeted at some point, you know,
when does all this computational approach
is kind of like emerging
and regarding the clinical
population, they were saying
bad news for clinicians.
They would have to learn mathematics
and statistics.
Right. To build computational models.
And which somebody replied,
is that bad news for mathematicians since
additions don't have to go to hospitals
and talk to the patients?
Right.
So there is I like that exchange
because this is the problem that we have
in a sense.
We really need a dialog between,
you know, the world out there,
need to go there, talk to the patient,
gather the data,
observe the insects,
you know, observe the human right.
You know, spent countless
hours is like measuring
how many eggs
they're laying and everything.
And in some time, you also need something
more rigorous that will allow you
to basically, you know, build models
that, you know, you know,
sort of like, yeah,
how should I put
this is like as if you you you
you test how I test this
instead of testing in real life,
you you let mathematics actually
take the risk of that hypothesis.
And if it's wrong, that's fine
because it's not going to die,
as you said, wrong hypothesis.
But in real life, if you test hypothesis
and you're wrong,
then actually you you may die.
So I think
that's should be very nice dialog
between the
two approaches
should be seen like the sort of like dig
in the same tunnel but from the opposite
sides
and hopefully meeting in in the middle.
Personally I like so I'm,
I like to even though I have a philosophy
background, I like to consider myself
as an interdisciplinary researchers.
So I have collaborators from all fields,
I collaborate with clinician psychology,
I'm doing experimental science.
So I'm running studies,
I'm collecting data.
I also collaborate
with people on the more formal side.
So it's been kind of like, you know,
simulation and formal approaches
to a certain set of phenomena,
especially connecting it
with my main interests,
which is self-awareness, minimal
selfhood, alteration of minimal selfhood,
the relation between the self on
the body and embodiment and
so on and so forth.
But, but yeah, I do.
And this is my just swears
that to the last, the last part
of my talk in the last slide,
that I'm very open to collaboration,
especially on that side,
because I really need to
and I really think we reached a point
where we basically need to have a dialog
because it's like
we have so much information in
and just we realize that to start
the life of the mind
and body noticing it so that we cannot
we cannot solve just like we just like
one single discipline or one single tool.
We really need to join forces.
And a dialog
is going to be a bit more messy,
a bit more trickier because we don't have
the same conceptual toolbox.
So we have to do a lot of work
before
we find what exactly we mean by that
right in different fields.
And I think this is
where philosophy can be useful
because we kind of like obsessed
with this idea.
What do you mean by,
you know, give me a definition
to make sure that actually we're
we're not all over the map in a we're
talking the same phenomena
about the same phenomena.
But also, I think it would be dangerous
for philosophy to to somehow develop
this conceptual toolbox completely cut
off from whatever, you know, you know,
to do things of that empirical world or,
you know, the mathematical models
to actually show what's right.
So we need to keep those gates open and,
you know, exchange and dialog
and collaborate. Wow.
Thanks for that awesome response.
To call back to your beginning slides,
you had the armchair philosopher
and that's a term that people know.
Just like in America,
we say a monday morning quarterback,
just like looking back at the past
and the armchair
philosopher is not so different, right.
And that made me think of
I think, therefore I am.
And the idea that by actually getting
into some sort of altered state
of inference, by meditating
or by doing some other
thought ritual, it would be possible
to reach insight through thought.
And the way that you just framed
the answer was like
hypothesis testing is an action
that we take in the world.
It's not just a thought.
And when we frame hypothesis
testing as action
about the systems that we care about,
like the next generations,
then it makes us
think about working on teams
and on accountability
and on reproducible science.
All these things that are sort of like
on the side
of the armchair philosopher
and the armchair philosopher might also
care about participation in science,
but that would be a secondary conclusion.
Whereas if hypothesis testing involves
stakeholders and it's also
something it's happening in the loop,
it's a, it's a different situation.
So it's just really like interesting,
I hope for those who are listening to
what you're.
Saying and actually I keep
I like to keep reminding my students
that, you know,
I put a picture of Descartes
because I'm thinking he's he's pictures
like to come to you.
Right. But it could have been Aristotle.
But I don't know.
It's like those kind
of like classic philosophers.
We need to keep in mind that
these people, I mean,
Aristotle was like biologists, right?
He was like constantly dissecting things
and, you know, testing things
as like as like looking at
what was going on with those organisms.
So Aristotle and he's considered to be
a great philosopher
and similarly with with court,
I mean, he was like a mathematician
and he wrote a treatise on optics, right?
So it's like and vision
and I think, yeah, so,
so science and philosophy are kind of
like working hand-in-hand,
I still think actually
working this back to,
but I really think that actually
scientists say
do it without realizing actually
no philosophy and some would philosophers
actually keeping and I went to this
like scientists are discovering
whatever nature is telling us right now
because it's like this is that constant
information processing, right?
We never get to the bottom
of any reality.
Things are changing, right?
There's like and I think
what is really fascinating with this
is an example of the virus, right?
Let's let's take the virus
because this kind of like very recent
and very relevant and very timely, right?
So if you are a classical armchair
philosopher,
then you have a huge ontological puzzle
with this virus because it's like just
loosely mutating, right,
in function of whoever is hosting
him. Right.
Or, you know, whoever
the host of that viruses
creates different types of mutation.
And this is like not a logical puzzle
for philosophy.
It's like, what is the virus
which is like coronavirus, which one is
it's like it's like
and you feel like saying was actually
none of them in all of them, right?
Because it's somehow all that kind
of like share this type of information.
But this change in function
of whichever body
or number of bodies and that depends on,
I don't know, the culture
and the food and just, you know,
I don't know, different genetic
all components and the factors.
And I, I can literally say that
we can literally see that
actually this is like
we actually have new beings coming,
you know, new, new entities arising
like mutants, mutant forms of like life.
It's like constantly arising so quickly
that think that we can't even, you know,
wait a minute.
Let me out what is going on right now?
So I think we have a very nice
in the humble
example, example of how
reality of their constantly
coming to us with like clues
themselves, like emerging information,
emerging creatures
living being, self-organizing system
and sometimes is like, well,
we can conceive that,
but actually they kind of like dangerous.
They can kill us
with all our sun.
And, you know,
and that's I think that's
a very important point
we need to bear in mind.
Yeah. Thanks for that.
It it made me think that it's
not just emerging entities, it's
actually emerging interfaces.
And even if the number of entities
were set, the interfaces would still be
combinatorial.
It would be explosions, just like words.
Even if the word vocabulary is set, you
still have interfaces that can emerge.
And then, as we say also here
in, the states
putting the cart
before the horse absolutely in error.
But then it's actually kind of something
that tells two layers of truth because.
It's philosophy and science
that are working together
in how we think about things
and how we operate things.
And what do we hear right now
other than there's a disconnection
between technology and society,
information flow, governance, decision
making, all these things you just,
you know, spin around
and pick a number and it will be related
to something like that.
And so that suggests
that there is a requirement
for a new kind of a conversation.
Yes, I fully agree.
Do you have any other thoughts otherwise?
This was really an awesome guest stream
and we all look forward
to hearing you in the future,
but you're always welcome.
Yeah, come on.
Whether you're doing it or not.
Yeah.
Let's hope that, you know, this was
kind of like develop more systematically.
And when I when the situation
allows you basically, you know,
organize that platform
perhaps in a workshop in person.
So meetings such as we can actually,
you know, put this idea to work
because I think that
just kind of like
no proximal face to face interactions
have a different
can can have a different type
outcome that,
you know, the ones we can have right now.
So we can basically,
you know,
consolidate the collaboration and dialog
on a more
concrete and pragmatic basis.
What I really I realized that
during the pandemic, what was really,
really fabulous is that, well,
now that's what's happening right now.
It never occurred to me that basic
Oh, well, wait a minute.
We can have like a Zoom conversation
with somebody from California
talking about this. So just kind of like,
you know, crisis,
you know, brought up
this new way of connecting
and make us
reach out in a way.
But I also think it's important to that,
you know,
range of put victims in place in the
first place to keep the balance right now
because we have evolved
going back to the human nature
and organism, we have evolved
to basically move and interact.
If you don't move,
we don't interact with simply die.
And we need to, you know,
keep moving and interacting each other.
And I think that's that's also
valid for different disciplines.
That's what we basically need
to adapt and interact
with each other as disciplines.
As active lab in online
participatory lab,
we will co embody that events in person
when your region is available
and when the personnel are there,
then we'll scaffold it in a new way
because previously it was all in-person.
There was never seen a need
to live stream
or never seen a need to document,
to translate, to make it accessible,
to make it available,
and will be able to organize in a new way
and be able to help each other in ways
that we wouldn't have expected before.
So I look forward to it.
Yeah, me too.
Great times.
See you again by bye. Bye.
Oh, nice, awesome stream.
Thanks, Ana.